في ردود الفعل الداخليه اكد التحالف
السوداني تحالف القوه الشعبيه في بيان ان
رئيس التحالف خميس ابكر والي ولايه غرب
دارفور قتل في احداث مؤسفه تدور في
الولايه منذ اسابيع ولم يحدد البيان الجهه
التي قتلت الوالد نجاتها وصفت حركته تحرير
السودان بقياده منياركم الناوي حاكم اقليم
دارفور مقتله الوالي بانه تصعيد غير
مسبوقه وقلم متحدث باسم الحركه الصادق على
النور ان اقتياد الوالي من مقر اقامته
اسيرا من قبل متفلته وتصفيته يخالف
المواثيق الدوليه الخاصه بالاسرى على حد
تعبيره جاتها دانت حركه العدل والمساواه
بقياده جبريل ابراهيم ما اسمته جريمه
اختطاف واغتيال الوالي واعتبرتها تطورا
خطيرا وامتدادا للانتهاكات الفظيعه التي
ارتكبت وما زالت ترتكب في الجنينه عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور حسب بيان للحركه كما
دانت الجبهه الثوريه مجموعه الهادي ادريس
مقتل الوالي ودعت لتشكيل لجنه تحقيق
مستقله لكشف الجناه وتقديمهم لمحاكمات
العادله جاته حملت تحالف الديمقراطي
للعداله الاجتماعيه ما وصفها دعم السريع
والقوه السياسيه الداخليه والقوى الخارجيه
التي تساندها وتدعمها مسؤوليه مقتل الوالي
الينا من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره اسامه سيد
احمد اسامه مرحبا بك معنا استعرضنا ما
يجري في دارفور وتحديدا الجنينه لكن ماذا
عن باقي الولايات وحيث انت في الخرطوم هذا
الصباح
الخرطوم هذا الصباح
[موسيقى]
وتفريقها وغير منتظمه ببعض المواقع من
الاسلحه ومتوسطه جمعناها اكثر من مره لكن
الطيران الحربي السوداني لا يزال يقوم
بالتحديث في مساحات واسعه من سماء العاصمه
السودانيه دون اي خط لاهداف ارضيه ولكن
الدعم السريع ضمن هذه الاصوات هي عده
مواقع في الواقع في الحقيقه يعني جنوب ام
درمان وغرب ووسط الحكم كذلك لكن لم
تستعجبهات قتاليه في اي موقع
مباشره او غير مباشره حتى هذه اللحظه لكن
حب الرخام طبعا تتجسد
تفاعلها الكثير منذ اكثر من اسبوع وهو ما
بقي طبعا من الفريق الذي قال منطقه
المستودعات التي تحوي الغاز والوقود
الجنوب الخرطوم وقرب مجمع اليرموك وهو احد
المؤسسات العسكريه التابعه لمنظومه
الصناعات الدفاعيه للجيش السوداني ربما
طبعا هو التطور الابرز في سياق هذه الحرب
المستمره لاكثر من شهر هو عمليه اغتيال
وادي ولايه غرب دارفور خميس عبد الله ابو
بكر بمدينه الفلينا مساء بعد ساعات من
الاحتفاقه طبعا
هذه الحادثه تعد تطور كبير وصادم في
الواقع للاوضاع الميدانيه والايسانيه
المتازمه بمدينه الجنينه منذ
عده اسابيع وطبعا تردد قضاء هذه الحادثه
عبر ردود افعال مختلفه كان من الجيش
السوداني الذي اصدر بيان المساء
فيه ما وصفه بالتطرف الوحشي
والغادر وتهم قوات الدعم السريع صراحه
باغتياله ايضا كان رئيس مجلس القياده هو
قائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
ايضا قد ادانا قتل هو تصفيه والي غرب
ودارفور واتهم ايضا قوات الدعم السريع
بتصفيته ردود الافعال يعني كثيره ومتواليه
كانت
منزله في الواقع بهذه الحادثه
جاءت هذه الردود الابعاد من
مثل الدقه الثوريه
بقياده
عضو مجلس السياده وحركه تحرير السودان
التي يقودها
مناوي
ووصفكم الناوي هذه الحادثه بالتقريب غير
المسبوق والخطير ايضا اشاره الاتهام الى
ما سماها
متفلته هي التي قامت بقتل لولايه غرب
مصدر بقوات الدعم السريع تحدث ان كان قد
تحدث للجزيره امس وادانا حادثه اغتيال
وادي ولايه غرب دارفور واشار وقال انه
مقتله جاء في اطار الصراع بين القبائل
العربيه وقبيله المساليف وحمل الجيش
السوداني مسؤوليه مقتل الوان بسبب تشليحه
لاحد النزاع القبلي واضاف منق بات الدعم
الاثريه التي كانت موجوده بمشرح الحادث
حاولت حمايه الوالي وتعرف بعض افراد لكن
طبعا في حديثه
في هذه المجموعه المهاجمه التي قال انها
كانت كبيره بحسب التعبير
صراحه لصبيحه هذه القوه المهاجره شكرا
جزيلا السيد احمد من الخرطوم